Israeli missiles continued to rain down
on the Palestinian territories in Gaza a
ceasefire was brokered but just after a
few hours air strikes resumed over 200
Palestinians have been killed in the
violence Hamas has rejected Egypt's
calls for a ceasefire as the Israeli
government is set to launch a
large-scale land offensive in the
strands Berg hemicycle enemies were
divided over what should be done the
Israeli missiles are launched randomly
lunch to cause without any concern for
saving civilian population and it looks
like indeed Israel thus expressly to
actually cause a maximum suffering in
innocence the populations such as
children and relatives of the ammas
leaders that it is supposed to be
targeting we now have a situation of
Gaza run by an EU band terrorist
organization Hamas in alliance with his
lamina had basically launching hundreds
and even thousands of missile attacks on
civilian areas in Israel which is a war
crime but M ep's did agree that peace
talks are the only way to resolve the
conflict fighting continues in East
Ukraine despite no official declaration
of war hundreds have been killed and
injured the EU says rushes back in
military fences by the pro-russian
forces Russia has not stopped the flow
of weapons equipment and two militants
across the border nor has it used its
influence or illegal armed groups in
eastern Ukraine to stop the violence and
get them to lay down their arms I mean
he's debated the situation in plenary
they also talked about developments of
the eu-ukraine agreement seminary peas
have called for sanctions against Russia
we need consequent action towards Russia
if Russia does not deescalate or fulfill
the requirements which we put on the
table council decision on further third
stage sanctions shall be put into motion
in sectors like the
fence banking and energy iraq is also in
the depths of its own severe and bloody
crisis Sunni Muslim rebels spearheaded
by Isis and Islamic extremist group risk
overthrowing the Shia Muslim that
government enemies in Strasburg debated
the right in response many called for a
political solution avoiding military
intervention nude / set apart a not
hawlucha monitor a phenom see Ali rock
before see Ibaka cohosh politique l4n
preetika diplomatically popular open key
swag clarinet its faith the crisis could
further destabilizing already desperate
Iraq